the ominous clouds of the Amazon
rainforest a storm is coming
the kovat 19 virus pandemic already has
the communities of the river have little
resilience to the diseases of the
outside world it's been a plague here
for over 300 years and it's back worse
than ever
we cut through a gap in the forest
entering another waterway you could
never find without a guide
and through the rain a hospital ship
the white man brought this virus they
say now the white man is trying to stop
its lethal spread into the indigenous
populations of the Amazon
there is not much these doctors can do
in the villages Community Center they
set up a triage area the medical staff
are trying to separate those who have
kovetz symptoms and those who are just
ill they're questioning everyone the
point is they have no way of telling who
has Co vyd who is asymptomatic and who
is infectious this is a very dangerous
place
the most obviously ill are led towards
dr. Ludmilla in a cos onus she's a
specialist in the covert 19 disease she
told me people in the community are
afraid because they live out here with
no access to medical care apart from the
river unit and these River communities
do have regular contact with the outside
world though they are meant to be cut
off in other communities even more
remote and we're still very remote here
but even more remote even the common
cold can wipe them out let alone
something like Kovac 19 the doctors are
really worried that a second wave of
this infection coming from the cities is
going to continue to spread into some of
the most remote part of the world what
the medics try to do is inoculate the
vulnerable against the h1n1 flu virus
it's simply to ensure that those who get
ill can be more easily identified as
Kovach victims as opposed to flu
what they don't know is how far this
virus is spreading away from the river
but local leaders say their villagers
have been ill and dying for weeks he
tell me he ravaged a noted philosopher
consider how to do a little teacher
sharing their the total support
it's a chewy
the Amazon River is a lifeline of these
people
it feeds them it transports them but now
even with limited access to the outside
world it's killing them mr. Ramsay
skynews in the Amazon